hello this
is dr cyril h wecht
i am a forensic pathologist and
medical legal consultant i am also
an attorney i don't practice law but i
utilize my legal knowledge background
and training
in the work that i do i
have been practicing as a forensic
pathologist since 1962
to the present time i
do autopsies for
four counties coroners and district
attorneys surrounding
pittsburgh allegheny county and private
autopsies
for families and attorneys upon request
i do consultations for attorneys
all over the united states and sometimes
from foreign countries
in a variety of civil and criminal
matters
it could be medical malpractice wrongful
death
um workers compensation on the civil
side
and it could be murder rape
sexual assault child abuse whatever
on the criminal side i've been doing
this then now
62 following completion of my training
five years in pathology following the
four years of medical school and a year
of internship
and three years of law school
i also served two years as a captain
in the united states air force during
that period of time
and served as an associate pathologist
at maxwell
air force base hospital in montgomery
alabama
i was the coroner of allegheny county
pittsburgh surrounding communities
for 20 years two separate 10-year
periods
1970 to 1980 1996 to 2006.
i had been an assistant district
attorney
for almost two years um back in the
mid 60s and served as a medical legal
advisor
to the district's attorney of allegheny
county
i'm pleased to have been invited
to make this presentation and i um
hope that all of you who are listening
to this
presentation will learn something from
it
i am very sorry that this cannot be a
live audience
i much more prefer that with that kind
of interchange and the opportunity for
questions
and comments so let me proceed
and i'll follow more or less um
a kind of an outline that i submitted
at the request of the
folks who are sponsoring um this program
and we chose as a title forensic
pathology
from crime scene to courtroom evidence
to testimony so let's start
we have the crime scene and it's
interesting in light of
what has been going on in calamitous
catastrophic fashion in the united
states of america
in just the past few weeks
months and what is still going on
with the charvin trial who now concluded
to go to the jury next week and with
other cases
um still being handled
the shooting of someone by an officer
using a gun instead of a taser
by a another video i saw today
of a 15 year old african-american boy
looks to me putting his hands up and
being shot
i i don't want to digress completely
into
uh police related deaths although we'll
certainly be talking about that and what
we shall be discussing
encompasses all of those kinds of cases
so we talk about the crime scene this
can be
known alleged or suspected crime scene
it may not necessarily be a crime scene
you don't know that
um when you have a
case reported to you a body being found
it could be in the water the lake the
ocean
a stream uh it could be
anywhere in a house on the road um
and it may appear to be someone who has
been traumatized
there could be blood and so on but you
don't know
do you is it a homicide accident or
suicide
let me point out um
the medical examiner the coroner and
i'll use those terms and refer to those
offices
in a kind of um you know overall
sense no differentiation for purposes
of this discussion the death certificate
ultimately to be written
by the office m e or coroner
includes not only the cause of death a
due to b due to c the contributing
factors
but also includes something not found
on a death certificate written
completed by a doctor whether it's a
private practice or at a hospital
and that's the manner of death those
death certificates
don't include matter of death
decisions the m.e coroners do and there
are
five possible manners of death in
decreasing order
of frequency of occurrence you have
natural
accident suicide homicide and
undetermined um and
you can see in the recently completed
presentation in the chaven trial
obviously the prosecution is saying it's
a homicide
the defense witnesses suggesting it
might be natural
and one of them said well he might have
signed it out as undetermined
um so keep that in mind so
back to the discovery of a body
you want to be very very careful uh in
not contaminating
the scene we have long known about this
going back to uh well locard's
principal l-o-c-a-r-d a french
criminalist
of the early part of the 20th century
that anytime there is a
contact between one person and another
or between a person
and some inanimate object there will be
the transfer
of evidence of that contact low cards
principle well it's
pretty true although with gloves and
things like that maybe you can
avoid leaving evidence but um
we're talking then about things which
are
beyond those that are obvious that are
immediately evident
but trace evidence and this includes
hair
fibers fingerprints shoe prints
little pieces of anything it could be
grass it could be soil
whether it's on somebody's shoes or
clothing or whatever
so all of that has to be kept in mind
when you have a scene you don't want to
contaminate it
because these are matters which while
seemingly trivial uh perhaps
to the viewer
at the beginning may in a courtroom
um with skilled attorneys
whether they're just being obnoxious um
as they can be brutal as they can be
as skilled and competent as they
frequently are
um you never know and they'll get into
something from the very beginning
so you should keep that in mind
if possible depending upon
the seeming appearance
of the case you may need to have the
forensic pathologist
and a criminalist and a forensic
photographer
as well as the homicide detectives
present at the scene
from the time the body is discovered
and nothing is contaminated the scene is
cut
off and nobody does anything until
these people come now unlike
television this isn't going to be the
case across the board
with of all deaths and nobody has that
kind of
manpower nor is it necessary
you know it's not required but um
it should be kept in mind
obviously in more rural areas you're not
going to have
such people available and in larger
metropolitan areas
while people like that are available
they're pretty busy too
going back several decades from the
beginning
for example of the medical examiner's
office
in 1877 in new york city it was
customary
for a pathologist from the office to go
to the scene
of every case well many years ago now
they discovered that was simply not
going to be
physically possible it just wasn't going
to be
feasible from a manpower standpoint and
so
um while that is uh
optimal um in
something that you you talk about uh
pragmatically speaking
it's not going to happen but um
taking pictures by his killed
photographer is important
because photographic evidence of
what was the position of the body what
was
the spread of the blood what was the
relationship
of articles of clothing where was the
gun
in relationship to the hand trying to
see
if it's a suicide versus an accident
versus a homicide
and so on so those are things
that you want to keep in mind
there's no hurry there's no rush the
individual is dead
you do want to check for rigor mortis
body stiffening libor mortis
gravitational settling
of blood in the dependent parts of the
body
depending upon the position of the body
when the individual dies
and al gore mortis body temperature that
should be done
and so frequently it is not done because
then as hours go by
the scientific validity of those
criteria
um becomes ever more
weakened these are not unlike a novel
fixed times to the minute or even to the
hour
there's a spread and so you want to move
quickly
failure to have done so for example in
the
nicole simpson case in the
jonbenet ramsey case that was very very
bad
because it was important to try to
determine when
nicole simpson and ron goldman in the
o.j simpson matter
died it was important to know when
jonbenet ramsey
died in reconstructing everything so
aside from that though
once you've done that then there's no
big hurry
so you should not rush the crime scene
review now the body is taken
by the representatives of
the medical legal investigative office
to
that office it is further identified
and again things have to be done
in documented fashion photography
is important along the way because
questions come up then
about again the position of the clothing
position of the head and the hand and so
on
as rigor mortis begins to maybe
leave the body as the body is being
moved
and repositioned inadvertently and so on
so these are things that need to be done
with the body there finally on the table
further identification
photography collection of evidence
routinely hair head hair
a body hair a pubic hair
are collected in cases
of suspected rape sexual assault of any
kind
um oral anal
erectile and vaginal swabs with a woman
oral and rectal anal schwabs with
a male so those things are
done fingernail scrapings um
and then fingernail clippings um are
done
and then if there are other things um
that need to be collected
uh items uh observations
on the clothing before the clothing is
removed
that is done in organized and
systematic fashion again photographing
things
as you proceed so
then um when all of that is taken care
of
the forensic pathologist moves in
with his her assistance and you begin
the actual dissection of the body
customarily i and i think most forensic
pathologists
prefer to open the head first because
that allows then
um blood to flow out
and um presents a more valid picture
uh when you get into the thoracic and
abdominal
organs you um make the incision
over the scalp observe what you have
beneath the scalp and then you remove
the calvarium
the bony top of the skull
and look to see any evidence of
epidural subdural subarachnoid
hemorrhage
then again photographing as you go along
anything of an abnormal nature and even
routine pictures to show
that there is nothing that is abnormal
or atypical when the brain is taken out
of the cranial vault
then you examine the base of the skull
and
document that then you examine the brain
in most cases the brain will be examined
at the time where the brain has been
traumatized
whether by accident suicide homicide
gunshot wound blunt force trauma
it is wise in cases that may be
homicides
or cases that present a problem to not
examine the brain at that time a brain
is
as much a viscous very thick liquid
as it is a solid in the fresh state and
when it is traumatized by gunshot wounds
it will begin to fall apart if you try
to cut it
so you fix it informally you may
remember from your high school
and university classes when you work
with specimens
in your biology class whether it was a
frog or a
whatever and so on you fix it in formula
and it hardens and not to be crude but
to get this point across
you now have something that had the
substance
of a well done soft boiled egg to begin
with
that would flow and fall apart to
a substance with
a firmness of a hard-boiled egg
so you seriously section it like you
would a hard-boiled egg and making a
salad
and now you can follow through this for
example
was not done in the john f kennedy
assassination
we came to learn later on that the brain
while removed and placed in formalin
properly
and while the pathologist went back two
weeks later they never dissected the
brain
they never examined it i had my thoughts
as to why
because it would have shown exactly that
there were two shots
that hit the president in the head one
from the rear
and one from the front but that's the
subject for another day
the point is that discussion
of a highly controversial nature
continues to this day
vis-a-vis the jfk assassination largely
because
the brain was not examined you can't do
that
you have to examine the brain properly
and you do that after two weeks
other times you fix the brain
and a neuropathologist examines it when
you're looking for
neurodegenerative disease processes
alzheimer's and the various
neurotrophic diseases parkinson's
amyotrophic
lateral sclerosis lou gehrig's disease
and multiple sclerosis
and so on with special stains
that the trained forensic
neuropathologist
does after you threw with that then you
open the
front of the body with a y-shaped
incision called that
you begin in front of the shoulders and
you come down
diagonally and then at the base of the
sternum the breastbone
continue in a straight line through the
abdomen you reflect the soft tissues
and then after you've checked the
ribcage and the sternum
then you remove the sternum electric saw
cutting it off
from the rib cage and you now have
access to
all the organs and tissues in the
thoracic
and abdominal cavities and into the
pelvic cavity
you look at everything in place remember
you're photographing
anything of an abnormal nature see if
there's any
liquid that has accumulated blood or
other fluids
and then before you go further
you collect things for
toxicological analyses that includes
blood
ideally taken from the femoral artery as
opposed to blood
from the heart it's more valid in terms
of the distribution pattern
as to what was extant in that body when
the individual died
more so than blood from the heart so you
get blood
ideally from that femoral artery then
you get bile bili from the gallbladder
urine from the urinary bladder
those are the basics you may
then be acquiring a tissue also
for toxological studies depending on
what you're looking for
gastric contents many times but the
three
body fluids that are important are blood
bowel and urine blood will tell you what
was present
when the individual died and therefore
what was being played out
physiologically um that which is in the
bowel will give you some idea of what
had
already been metabolized by the liver
and stored
in the gallbladder which is what bowel
is the liver metabolizes
and stores and then urine later
after everything has gone through and
they've been excreted
by the kidneys so again referring to the
chauvin case
testimony by the defense about george
floyd
having ingested some pills or substance
after he was arrested
it's there's no consequence the total
total
ludicrous nonsense designed to confuse
the jury
because aside from the fact whether or
not he did that
is of no consequence because that which
he may have taken into his mouth
during this altercation that went on for
some minutes
would have had no meaning at all going
into the stomach
it takes 30 40 minutes even on an empty
stomach to be absorbed how different
does it make this is the kind of
nonsense that i
you know as an attorney and a medical
legal person really despise
uh i recognize what attorneys try to do
but uh that doesn't make it um
more palatable and acceptable to me
because i consider it to be
unethical and improper and
a sign of lack of some
competency and basic decency
so now after you've acquired those
specimens
you begin to remove your organs usually
most of the time organs are removed
separately sometimes
they remove we say on block en
bloc on block together but most of the
time
individually you weigh you measure
you um feel you get a sense of the
consistency
and you describe things you again
have your assistant or the photographer
depending again on the nature of the
case if it's a gunshot wound case
you want to document as you proceed in
from the gunshot wound
of entrance that you've identified into
the
body organs and tissues where did the
bullets reverse
and then you go all the way through to
the exit wound
and then sometimes you may insert a rod
to show the directionality of that
gunshot wound
just this past week we had two multiple
gunshot wound cases
for chicago and new york uh it's routine
probably daily uh we're not a rural
community
in pittsburgh and the communities for
which i do autopsies
but still a two multiple gunshot wounds
within a matter of a few days is not
that common
even in one of those homicide
centers and that's those are difficult
cases
you've got to identify and differentiate
between
entrance and exit contrary to what
people believe
sometimes it's not clear-cut as to what
is entrance and what is exit
depending upon the um the location of
the
of the weapon in relationship to the
body
and whether there's gunshot powder
residue a deposited
stippling pattern um that comes out
with the burning carbonaceous particles
within 24
18 24 inches fired from
the victim and so on so
you do all of that then you take pieces
of tissue after you've weighed and
measured
and palpated and described everything
you take what we call
representative sections you take pieces
of all of the major organs and smaller
organs
and submit them in formalin we call them
representative
sections because you want to get
something which is representative of
both pathological changes as well as
normal appearing tissues and those are
placed in formalin for microscopic
slide preparation just like the hospital
pathologist
gets the appendix or the lung tumor or
the piece of kidney
from the hospital surgeon um
he she examines it and makes a slide
and looks at it under the microscope
it's the same thing
with the forensic pathologist
so now you've got working for you
toxicological analyses uh by
a toxicologist in a separate laboratory
and you've got slides being made you may
have made some cultures
sometimes you want to see if there's an
infectious process
so you do a culture with a swab
and you get back to these slides
of the swabs you've made looking for
possible
evidence of rape sexual assault
looking for seminal fluid looking for
spermatozoa and so on um
and you're getting all of that to come
back
to you now you're getting
further information from your own
personnel
as well as the
homicide detectors and so on and you put
everything together
i want to make a very important point
um you do not
rely upon information from the police
and homicide investigator if it were
scientific testimony
you are not an adjunct of
the prosecution look at the national
academy
of sciences report in late february
of 2009 they made it clear
this most prestigious group of
scientists in the world
national academy of sciences making it
very clear
something that i talked about for
decades not that i was
the first or only person but i was so
proud and thrilled
to see that published in february of 09
that the people in the fields of
forensic science
whether the pathologist the criminalist
whoever you are
not a norm you are not an extension of
the prosecution
you are functioning as a forensic
scientist
so unlike the pathologist
in the george floyd case the hennepin
county medical examiner
who gave a diagnosis of cardiopulmonary
arrest
occurring during the subduel of the
victim
during physical restraint
uh application of physical restraints
and so on
total total prosecutorially biased
way of presenting a case first of all
cardiopulmonary arrest
is not something you see grossly or
microscopically
it means heart and lungs stop right
cardiopulmonary arrest
when you die everybody you're going to
have cardiopulmonary arrest
if there's a clinician present when
somebody goes into that kind
of clinical situation then he she can
say
cardiopulmonary arrest they see it they
hear it with a stethoscope they view it
on the electrocardiogram you're not
saying that at the autopsy table
as number number two you don't use that
information
from the police during subdue
a noun you won't even find in some
dictionaries
um we know what it means
uh enduring the uh attempt to restrain
or whatever and so on um this kind of
partiality
was demonstrated during the testimony
the medical examiner
who testified obviously with great
discomfort and displeasure
called by the prosecution so you take
all this together and then you put
together a postmortem protocol the
autopsy report
that autopsy report should contain
things
of an objective scientific nature if you
want to express
opinions then you may be consulted
by attorneys by the district attorney by
whomever
families in private cases that's a
separate
written document called a medical legal
report
when i get a consultation and i do an
autopsy
i give my autopsy report that's one
thing
and the consultation report is separate
you do not admix your subjective
interpretations with the objective
findings
i want to pound that point home
understand you're a forensic scientist
if you want to be a police officer or a
homicide detective
wonderful pursuits do that don't get it
confused
with being a forensic scientist i pound
that point home
with students any who are listening make
up your mind
you want to be a policeman you want to
be a district attorney
or you want to be a criminal defense
attorney or do you want to be a
scientist
keep that in mind so there's your final
post-warning protocol
and your medical legal consultation
report
i see now we've come to 30 minutes i
hope i have covered everything for you
from beginning uh to end from
um crime scene to courtroom um
evidence to testimony i hope
that i've made some points that will be
helpful to you
as you pursue your present and future
careers
and maybe if you are a teacher keep
these in mind
things to get across to your students
thank you very much
folks i wish you well in all of your
future endeavors
best wishes